well American politics is increasingly
haunted by a strange new Spectre the
woke billionaire they got a ton of money
but otherwise they sent a lot like
socialists how does that work exactly
venture capitalist Nick Hanauer recently
declared that Alexandria Kazuya Cortez
is it the very beating heart of American
politics and he's for that watch it's
easy to call what AOC is doing as far
lefty but nothing could be further from
the truth
when you advocate for economic policies
that benefit the broad majority of
citizens that's true centrism what
howard schultz represents the center ism
he represents is really just
trickle-down economics tax cuts for rich
people deregulation for powerful people
and wage suppression and benefit cuts
for everyone else without the overt
racism he is not the centrist aoc is
this interest it's woke billionaire
versus woke billionaire meanwhile
there's Tom Steyer he uses his vast
wealth a lot of which he got from fossil
fuels to organize and lead impeachment
rallies he may be the locus t' i will be
dedicating 100% of my time effort and
resources to one cause working for mr.
Trump's impeachment and removal from
office start impeachment now now the
impeachment question has reached an
inflection point 100 percent for
impeachment and insist that this
president be impeached and removed
so when billionaires started noticing
socialist policies call me skeptical but
you think maybe there's a scam afoot how
are they benefiting from this you know
they are author and columnist mark Stein
has some ideas about that knee joint
says hey what's going on here mark Stein
well I think the woke billionaire is a
phenomenon of our time the way you get
rich now is not the way you got rich in
the days of the 19th century robber
barons in the Gilded Age it's possible
to do it now while being evermore
disconnected from the concerns of
ordinary people so these work
billionaires I think they're a lot like
rock stars you know Borno for example
goes on about debt forgiveness for
Africa but when he wanted to save money
he moved his music publishing firm from
Dublin to Amsterdam for the lower taxes
he doesn't move it to Wagga dugu and
give a big injection into the African
economy and I think that's actually the
way these guys are they they understand
that they're in a world in which
striking attitudes that preserve their
own power base is actually more
important than than anything else well
exactly and they're smart enough because
they are smart by and large that's how
they got rich to understand that there
there's a lot of roiling politics right
beneath the surface and the main theme
going forward is to be populist
economics and guys like them could get
crushed so do you think they're this is
a defensive move yes I think it is we
have declining social mobility in the
United States which is a tragedy and we
have across the planet a huge rise in
the growth of billionaires controlling a
small group of about 2000 billionaires
controlling an ever greater share of the
the world's wealth and it's easy to
strike attitudes at home while then
taking advantage of tax loopholes abroad
so you know Google doing the old double
Irish as they call it by rooting its
money from one Irish company to another
and then into a British tax haven like
like Bermuda the whole point is to
actually create a world in which there's
an elite at the top and a vast mass
underneath and not a lot of and the
escalator to get from the bottom to the
top is running ever slower and with a
never a fewer people able to get on it
so don't you think though there should
be some standard I mean if you're a
billionaire who's gonna go on MSNBC and
call for revolution shouldn't we get to
see your tax returns and assess the tax
havens that you're using to prevent
paying your fair share I mean isn't that
sort of a minimum requirement for this
well I think actually the the on the
Left there's a huge
acceptance now that the rules they want
to apply to others don't apply to them
so if you made your money in say coal or
construction and you want to keep your
your and you want to keep that money in
the Cayman Islands or Bermuda or the
Channel Islands you're a bad person but
if you're you know you don't even have
to be a businessman if you're the
Southern Poverty Law Center and you you
have that ridiculous name and yet you
have billions salted in as I said
British colony tax havens then that's
okay that the left has a high degree of
tolerance because they actually they
actually think it's different when they
do it that's their basic that's their
basic view of it and I think that's true
with with these guys I mean everyone
knows you can salt all your money away
in these little Irish Bermudan tax
loopholes not pay tax here but still get
invited to the Obama White House and be
standing between Obama and Bill Clinton
it won't affect that there's never been
a more hypocritical age or a smarter
analyst of it than Mark Steyn thank you
for that
thanks a lot Tucker